this is the imperial prince he's the
sole surviving descendant of an ancient
clan that once dwelled in this land but
now he's alone with no one except for a
loan loyal shinobi the two of them have
each other and no one else that is until
the commander of this region hatches a
plot to kidnap the prince this commander
personally defeats our shinobi kidnaps
our young master and sets the events of
the game into motion but shadows die
twice or to quote the Japanese title we
will enjoy we awaken in an abandoned
temple and if it's the same as the
temple that's burning in the intro then
it may well belong to the goddess of
mercy alongside us is a boo she who is
obsessively carving countless statues of
the Buddha these statues are typically
created in the image of one who has
obtained Buddhahood or enlightenment so
it's curious then that many of these
statues appear to have two torsos and
four arms often with the left arm
missing and the bushi and our character
two are also missing their left arm but
ours has been replaced with an indicia a
ninja prosthetic arm so it's with this
says the bushi that will be better
equipped to get back our honor and
rescue a young master and this is the
man who took him he's the commander of
the escena clan and thanks to the
Japanese sikita website we actually
already know a ton about his history so
we don't know the commanders name but
his grandfather was called escena ition
and he was a Ken say which literally
translates to sword st. basically it's
somebody who has a legendary skill in
swordsmanship
he was an inspiring figure and in his
time he rested control of this region
and embedded the escena clan within it
the official site stresses that he did
this in just one generation and it
labels him as a hero of the
northern country however now two
generations later with his grandchild in
command the escena clan is described as
being in a life-or-death crisis a
hostile force is encroaching upon their
territory and they seek to wipe out the
entire clan and fighting between clans
was really common at this time the game
is set in feudal Japan after all and
this was the age of warring States the
Sengoku period so the escena clan of
sukira rising to power and then facing
defeat less than two generations later
fits perfectly with the era and here's
the really interesting thing the escena
clan actually existed during this period
it's not even made up so for the first
time we're gonna see some parallels with
law and history
so the escena clan in japanese history
was this clan that claimed its descent
from another major japanese clan of
samurai called
the Taira clan and i can't find too much
information on how the actual lishchyna
clan was run but they eventually
suffered two major defeats that led to
the death of the clan
so the defeat of the escena clan is
really well documented and is worth
talking about their defeat because it
looks like the in-game escena clan is
facing a very similar fate according to
the official website the commander of
the escena is terribly anxious and
secretly informs his own troops that
there's no ordinary or natural means of
protecting the escena from the attacking
army we definitely need that Prince now
that's interesting
the commander believes that our prince
is their only hope of protection so who
is this Prince and why is he so
important we know a lot about the prince
but we're gonna have to break it down so
the prince is a part of an ancient clan
that precedes the escena in this region
however around the time that the escena
took control this prince appears to have
lost his clan and family and was raised
instead by one of the Ishino clans
lesser subjects the vassal Hirata
now the Hirata could be a lesser clan of
Shiina but it could also be a person as
someone named Edyta
ki Inori was actually a general within
the real life a Sheena clan around this
time after the prince was passed on and
taken care of by Hirata it seems that we
a capable shinobi were charged with the
princes protection instead that is until
he was stolen from us by the commander
of the Ishino who needs him back so now
we know who the princess but we still
have to ask why does the commander
believe that having the prince will
solve the problem of an oncoming army
well the bushy and the trailer specifies
that the word bloodline is curious so
remember we don't know the princes
specific origins except that he's
considered royalty of an ancient clan so
I think there's two ways that kidnapping
the prince could protect the escena from
an oncoming army there's an ordinary
reason and there's an extraordinary
reason so the ordinary reason would be
because the princes family history might
be important to the oncoming army after
all at the time of feudal Japan you can
kind of imagine that kidnapping someone
might be a really good idea if you want
to use them for political leverage
so when bushy says they'll soon make use
of his bloodline they could simply be
talking about the value of the princes
royal heritage or and this is more
interesting they could be talking about
the princes bloodline in a far more
extraordinary literal sense from
software has a really long history of
bloody sacrifice in their games and I
wouldn't be surprised at all to see the
commander invoking some sort of
supernatural power with the princes
blood using the princes bloodline this
does sound like it's a last resort after
all and given there's a centipede fusion
man seen in the trailer no one should be
too surprised I think to cease Aikido
taking on a supernatural twist just like
blood bonded and this brings us to the
leaks about
sekito which mentioned quite a bit of
stuff that's relevant so a lot of the
information here has already been
validated but please take the following
with a grain of salt so according to the
leaks the story of Socorro is going to
feature an ancient cult fearful of the
world's end that sacrifices people at
their shrine of blood as a way of for
stalling the end of the world a central
question is supposed to be whether the
cult is really evil or whether they're
just more well informed than the rest of
us and almost as if to verify these
leaks a little bit further there
actually was a mention of a cult at e3
where journalists go to watch a more
detailed gameplay demo so during the
demo the player runs into an old lady
and then they kill her in cold blood it
was explained that she is a part of an
evil cult and if they didn't kill her
then she would have called for
reinforcements so you know I wouldn't be
surprised to see the commander of the
Agena giving in to cultish sacrifice of
the prince as a sort of last resort to
save his clan until games come rolls
around in late August that's probably
going to be it from me for cicchitto
content but if we hear about anything
else please subscribe and you will see
it on this channel if you haven't seen
them already we have two videos that go
in-depth on the gameplay of Sakura so
check those up special thanks to Loki
for helping me translate literally
everything the day the trailer released
I didn't even get to mention this in the
video but there's a war banner in the
trailer and we translated it and it says
something along the lines of there is no
better combo than loyalty and bravery
and lay down your life for your country
I really hope that they have more stuff
for us to translate in secular more
environmental clues and woods and stuff
like that because if they're getting rid
of a lot of items in sekito I wonder how
are they going to use item descriptions
to tell the story
message for patrons I will be streaming
again very soon and to everyone I'll see
you next time
[Music]